il n'ya pas d'autre choix que de voter
contre l'extrême droite je voterai donc
en faveur d' emmanuel macron faire
barrage aux extrêmes au second tour ça
s'appelle le front républicain une
vieille pratique politique qui a volé en
éclats lors de la dernière
présidentielle
il est 20 heures le 23 avril 2017
emmanuel macron et marine le pen sont
qualifiés pour le second tour de la
présidentielle quelques minutes plus
tard le candidat de la droite françois
fillon appels au front républicain
contre le front national il nous faut
choisir ce qu'il y a 2 préférable pour
notre pays je ne le fait pas de gaieté
de coeur mais l'abstention n'est pas
dans mes gènes
surtout lorsqu un parti extrémiste
s'approche du pouvoir le front national
ce parti créé par jean marie le pen a
une histoire qui est connu pour sa
violence et pour son intolérance dès
lors il n'y a pas d'autre choix que de
voter contre l'extrême droite je voterai
donc en faveur d' emmanuel macron
françois fillon votre à macron mais très
vite son party les républicains se
divise sur cette question certains sont
pour le front républicain mais d'autres
refusent de choisir entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen c'est ce qu'on
appelle le ni-ni appelés à voter
emmanuel hollande
mais là je tombe de l'armoire une
deuxième fois j'ai
un programme un bon programme d'ailleurs
que j'ai combattu à gauche le front
républicain vole aussi en éclats et
socialiste appelle à voter emmanuel
macron mais du côté de la france
insoumise jean luc mélenchon arrivé en
quatrième position avec 19 5% des voix
refuse de donner une consigne de vote
chacun chacune d'entre vous
cette en conscience quel est son devoir
dès lors je me range
je n'ai reçu aucun mandat des quatre
cent cinquante mille personnes qui ont
décidé de présenter ma candidature
pour m'exprimer
à leur place
sur la suite ce silence de jean luc
mélenchon fait bondir une partie de la
classe politique et notamment les
soutiens des manuels battrons comme
françois bayrou j'ai été stupéfait qu'il
ne se prononcent pas dimanche soir
j'aurai j'aurais parié à peu près de
tout ce que j'avais que ça ne serait pas
le cas et comme les
que vous compreniez que sont blessés
tous ceux qui avaient mis leur confiance
ou en tout cas l'immense majorité de
ceux qui avaient mis leur religion
doivent recevoir le discours demain
alors face à la polémique jean luc
mélenchon organise une consultation des
militants de la france insoumise et au
final deux tiers des votants refuse de
choisir entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen est en terre cette idée de front
républicain
[Musique]